it is indeed a jumble of numbers and I
have to admit that political journalists
are being briefed as we speak on exactly
what these mean by Dada Harding who is
in charge of that test track and trace
regime so actually there will be more
information on this when we've had that
full briefing but what we can say for
now is that eight thousand people around
eight thousand people as you say were
identified with having covered 19 and
around 5000 of them actually provided
contact details that's all the people
that they've been in close contact with
they provided that to the contact traces
now those contact traces then went out
and rang them and that ended up in
around 32,000 people being contacted to
say that you may or may not have had
contact with someone who had coronavirus
26,000 of them were asked to self
isolate now what we don't know at the
moment is the number who actually have
agreed to self isolate and that really
is crucial because of course this is a
test track and trace regime that relies
on people are daring to the instruction
to stay at home but there's no
enforcement of that rule at the moment
the government has said that they expect
people to take it seriously and to stay
at home if there's any potential that
they might have come into contact with a
sufferer the whole system breaks down if
they don't do that so it's going to be
crucial to find out how many have
actually agreed to self isolate and
we'll bring you those figures when we
have them what we do know though is that
around 79% of those contacts were
reached within 24 hours so not quite a
hundred percent the government will be
aiming to get as close to that as they
possibly can because of course the
longer you're left to roam around in the
community the more potential people you
come into contact with and the whole
point of this system as we know is to
try to control the spread of the virus
speaking to people who have been working
on it behind the scenes they see these
numbers as pretty positive they think
it's a good first step and they are of
course moving towards making it work
more effectively as the lockdown is
lifted but there's still a missing link
in this whole test system and that's the
app we were told that that was going to
be crucial to helping people know who
they'd come into contact with we're now
told that when lockdown is lifted so
later on this year that will become more
crucial because when people start to
move around more and they come into
contact with more people then the app
will be useful in helping people to
track who they may have come into
contact with over time at the moment
because most people are in
down and therefore not moving that much
the contact tracing system can be done
by humans at the end of a telephone one
interesting thing to note from the Isle
of Wight testing that's been done the
results actually show that people are
much more inclined to listen if it's a
person telling them they need to self
isolate rather than an app so that may
well have guided the government's
thinking on how to proceed with this
test track and trace system yeah that's
an interesting finding isn't it just on
the social distancing Kate we just heard
Nicola Sturgeon restating the argument
for the two meter rule to be continued
with we'll be talking to Ian Devlin
Smith Tori grandi former Conservative
Party leader in the next few minutes he
will argue the opposite that one metre
is good enough for most of the world not
good enough for the UK will help
business where are we heading on that
well he's not alone in Duncan Smith is
one of a number of very senior backbench
Conservative MPs and actually there are
ministers too who are asking Boris
Johnson to do this as quickly as
possible and they want it to happen
because there are a number of bars and
restaurants other venues where people
mix in close proximity who say that they
just can't operate they won't be
financially viable if the 2 meter
guideline is stuck to by the government
it's also a problem for schools because
trying to get all the pupils crammed
into classrooms and keeping them apart
is proving problematic there's not
enough space we know actually that
Downing Street and Boris Johnson also
keen to lift this restriction but they
will only do so when they know that the
infection rate in the community is low
enough to do it without a huge risk of
the virus getting out of control again
the problem is at the moment we don't
know what that level has to be so we've
got no guidance as to when that might
happen
but what we do know is that scientists
have said 2 metres is safe at the moment
because it reduces the risk from the
droplets from your mouth you can reduce
that distance to 1 metre but you might
need to use other things like a mask you
may need to sit next to somebody rather
than across from them if for example you
were in a restaurant and the government
is sending a message that they are
looking at this as a matter of urgency
here is a government minister speaking
to us a little bit earlier on today
everybody should maintain to meet the
social distancing are at this point this
is the clear guidance that we've issued
to everybody it's what we want people to
observe we would love to make progress
on this point but we're not yet
do that you know clearly we do take into
account our own scientific and they've
been very clear that this is what they
recommend at the end of the day though
this will be a political decision the
scientists will advise Boris Johnson but
he will be the man who has to decide
when it is the right time to reduce that
limit and there will be implications
from that decision of course and this is
still a very new virus that lots of
people don't really fully understand so
a difficult time for Boris Johnson but
he is being pushed by all sides to make
that decision sooner rather than later